Donald Trump's transition team announced
that people who leave the administration
will have to wait five years before they
can become lobbyists I want to put a
quote up on the screen for you from
Trump transition team spokesman Sean
Spicer who said it goes back to Trump's
goal to make sure people aren't using
government to enrich themselves the key
thing for this administration is going
to be that people going out of
government won't be able to use that
service to enrich themselves for a
five-year period so everybody who joins
the administration is going to be asked
to sign a lobbying ban form which states
that they are not registered lobbyists
to begin with and if they are they have
to provide evidence of termination so
this is utterly and totally meaningless
number one current lobbyists candy
register as lobbyists and then asked to
join the administration there's no
statement in there about how long you
have to not be a lobbyist before joining
and this is already happening there's an
aide to mike pence who is a Washington
lobbyist his name is Josh pitcock which
is a fascinating name as far as I know
his real name filed paperwork with the
Senate on Monday to terminate his status
as a federal lobbyists I wonder why he
did that and then we get to the post
Trump part after working in the Trump
administration you're banned from being
a lobbyist to the executive branch for
five years are you understanding the
letter of this number one instead of
being a lobbyist which is a term that
has a legal registration involved you
can be a consultant instead and yes as a
consultant you can do almost all of the
same things that a registered lobbyist
can do not everything but a lot of those
same things and by the way Pat you can
also lobby Congress you can't Lobby the
executive branch you can't be a lobbyist
to the executive branch for five years
but the band says nothing about lobbying
Congress were a whole hell of the
lobbying goes on right i mean who
actually makes the laws it's Congress if
you want to get rid of the revolving
door between government and K Street you
have to go after Capitol Hill first and
foremost this is one of these
there's so many loopholes this is like
Swiss cheese and an example is former
Senator Tom Daschle he worked as a
policy advisor at lobbying firms after
leaving the Senate in 2005 uh it's just
unbelievable the entire thing is
completely bogus there is no draining of
the swamp happening and people are being
tricked into believing that Trump is
doing it Donald Trump's administration
mark my words and we're already seeing
it it is going to be the height of
establishment insider crony politics as
usual in every way there's lobbyists on
the transition team administration
officials becoming lobbyists not in name
but in spirit will be absolutely allowed
and we've already seen Donald Trump walk
back eight probably nine campaign
promises at minimum we talked about that
last week bringing in the totally
typical neoconservatives to his
administration already I'm not seeing
anything here Pat other than the heavy
concentration of deplorable Xand racists
that are being recruited for Trump's
cabinet that is different from the
standard status quo Republican
administration this is business as usual
right i think most of the people who
have supported them are now just gonna
turn the other way they don't care as
much as much anymore now these got into
office they want access we saw mitt
romney who said i mean he said
absolutely horrible things about Donald
Trump you would think he said things
about Trump that are completely
unfixable right that it's just
intractable a total impasse he met with
Trump over the weekend is reportedly
being considered for the Secretary of
State position which by the way makes a
lot more sense than Rudy Giuliani but
that's a sort of different discussion
for a different time uh what are are we
getting the change that Trump promised
are the trumpets prepared to have
America made great again by this total
and utter nonsense is spectacular it is
striking but it is not altogether
surprising when you consider
particularly but Donald Trump didn't
even really understand most of the
promises that he made on the campaign
trail and you know that we will continue
following